i want to introduce kathy davies she is
the managing director of the stanford
life design lab
and the design the life design studio
lead
so in addition to her roles there she
has 15 years of experience developing
electromechanical and software products
and proudly holds five patents she
consults with silicon valley companies
teaches design thinking as we'll find
out today conducts ethnographic research
and develops product strategies and
concepts if that were enough she's
already a renaissance woman she also is
the co-creator of designing your life
for women and a passionate advocate for
design thinking as a methodology to
empower social change
and so uh
there's a lot there kathy so welcome i'm
really excited for having me
i should probably also add on the mother
of two teenage daughters so maybe that's
even harder than all of those other
things
i yes that might be the hardest thing uh
on on the bio especially this job of all
three years yeah
wow oh thanks for having me pax
it's it's yeah it's great to have you
and i think because we have such a big
audience probably the place to start
with just providing some context on
design thinking so it i know it's at the
core of your approach to a lot of things
you do in particular designing your
career and designing the professional so
could you give us the 30 000 foot view
of what design thinking is
yeah absolutely design thinking at its
core is a human-centered process for
problem solving
so it's really about placing people
first
and thinking about how we can solve
problems for them and there's a set a
set of five steps that people think of
when they think of design thinking the
first one is empathize who are the
people you're trying to serve
in the case of designing your own life
and career that might be yourself
then there's define what do you think is
worth working on where do you want to
focus your time and energy
i think a lot of times when people think
of design thinking they think of the
third step ideate which is all about
generating lots and lots of ideas
getting really divergent getting ideas
that you wouldn't normally have and i
want to say that ideation is awesome but
that defined step really determines the
kind of ideas that are available to you
so the defined step is a key bit and i
think it's often overlooked so empathize
define ideate once you have a bunch of
ideas then you've got to try them out in
the world and we call that prototyping
how do you test them in a small way to
figure out if there's a there there if
you should invest more time energy and
resources and that testing step that
fifth step is about taking what you've
built back to the people that you're
hoping to serve and figuring out is this
something that is on to the problems
they were really curious about solving
does this meet their needs and so you
might test something with yourself hey
how is this working for me how do what
do i notice and all of these steps are
really kind of a bumpy road you can
iterate and change step um from one to
the other it's not linear at all it's
really a
cycle of iteration of building your way
forward if you will
that's fascinating and uh i thank you
for the clear sort of five step
breakdown um
so i guess following on that you know so
when i think of design thinking and it's
in your bi your bio as well so i think
of it as something that you're applying
to developing a product so you know i
want to create a new type of software a
new electro-mechanical system
so can you tell us a little bit more
about the life design lab which first of
all sounds like probably the coolest lab
on stanford's campus and then how that
lab or how the lab was created and came
to
use design thinking to helping people
think about their life and their career
yeah absolutely the lifestyle lab was
actually founded in 2007 it was founded
by our two lab founders bill burnett and
dave evans who went on to write the book
designing your life and then the book
designing your new work life
and these two guys got together and they
were just really looking at what was
going on with students so as you think
about that design thinking process i
just mentioned they were using design to
design curriculum and they were asking
themselves what's going on with students
at that time and what was going on was
the same thing that's going on with
students now and in fact a lot of you
out there probably mid-career
professionals folks who are thinking
about
what do i want to be when i grow up or
what do i want to grow into
as i become the next me in the next
phase of my career or life and folks are
really struggling with this question at
that time students were really
struggling particularly in product
design because product design was a
relatively new field and many students
were leaving school with this question
of well how do i tell my story how do i
how do i apply this to work that matters
in the world and so these two guys sat
down to create a class using design
thinking because that's the
structure that they were teaching in
product design classes and would be very
familiar to students to work on personal
and professional development what would
it look like to design your life and
your career
and
the uptick was immediate students were
very excited to have these conversations
they weren't able to have these
conversations in any other space and
that structured set of activities really
gave them a process to engage with how
do they become really more conscious and
competent in designing their life and
career so
that then started a tiny pilot class
that became larger and larger it was
originally
offered just to product design students
than harry elam and some other folks
from the vice provost office came in and
said do you offer this more broadly so
then it was offered to all students
and then the invitation was well what
about designing your time at college and
so we set up set out to design a class
called designing your stanford
that then helps students land at school
and think about how they wanted to
design their education for the four or
five years that they would be here so
our swedo offerings has become designing
your stanford designing your life for
juniors and seniors and then designing
the professional which is for graduate
students and now potentially mid-career
professionals
yeah and and maybe just um
you know you mentioned taking the
structured approach to it because i i
know you know there was nothing like
this when i went to college right it was
like you go to go to the the career
resources office and they can review
your resume or something like that or
give you tips on applying so could you
i mean i i think to some extent the
value is self-evident but could you
build out why is it so important and to
approach designing or thinking about
your career in life in a structured way
or what feedback have have you gotten
yeah i think that's a really good
question and i think mainly that the
benefit of having a structure is that
you are held in some sort of a process a
lot of us have these sort of broad
philosophical questions but where to
start is just not clear and especially
now when there's so much ambiguity we've
gone through two years of incredible
change the pandemic has been really
challenging for many of us
maybe we've lost jobs maybe our home
situation has shifted maybe our
financial situation has shifted
we're feeling lost and confused and so
having a process where we can locate
ourselves hey what might be a logical
next step how could i start addressing
some of these questions is really
helpful and the thing i like about
design thinking in particular is it
doesn't assume anything about where you
are or what resources you have or what
your situation is it just meets you
wherever you are it invites you to
empathize with yourself to define things
that matter to you in this moment it
invites you to come up with ideas that
are applicable to your current situation
and to try them out given whatever
resources you have and what i like about
this in the face of ambiguity is it's
comforting right there's structure
enough structure that i know what i
might do next but it's not so confining
that i feel like oh man i must be doing
it wrong so it invites all of us into
the process
so when the world around you is so
chaotic and unstructured it's useful to
have a way of approaching it that is
structured and that in itself kind of
gives you a way of organizing it um
we're getting so i want to go a little
bit off script is related to this next
question we have planned but we're
getting a lot of these questions well so
what are some specific examples so you
laid out the five steps i'm going to
repeat them i empathize define
uh id8 prototype and then test could we
maybe just walk through what what might
you do so you know we have people here
right now can you just give us an
example what would
what might you be doing on that first
step of empathize i mean
yeah
you're in the audience yeah we in our
classes really invite people to do some
work to understand themselves and so a
core piece of that is assessing where
you're at right now and so we ask people
to do some writing as designers what are
they looking for in work and by that i
don't mean a job description i mean
what's your philosophy
philosophy of work why work at all
what's the purpose of work what's the
purpose of work for you as an individual
for you as playing a role in your
community what does money have to do
with it what does meaning have to do
with it what does personal growth have
to do with it so we invite folks to
actually spend some time reflecting and
writing down their thoughts and
typically that's about a half page to a
page we keep it pretty concise then we
also ask folks to think about what's
their view of life what's their world
view so to speak and asking really big
questions why are we on this planet what
are we doing here what what is the
role of a higher power in your in your
life and experience what is the role of
your personal narrative in your
experience what are the key guiding
principles that you might think are
important as you approach life and then
we look at those two things together to
create a compass are they coherent with
one another where do they clash where do
they energize each other and just that
noticing in that empathize hexagon gives
us a foundation to build from and it
also gives us a sense of hey if these
two things are together going to
potentially point us in some direction
how can we use it then in our decision
making how can we evaluate opportunities
to notice does this fit
with who we are
what we believe and what we think we
want to do
and so it's a very helpful
compass or
strategy i think to start with and to
start understanding ourselves we also
spend some time thinking about our own
identities and the narratives that we've
grown up with what are the stories that
we've heard from our families what are
the stories we're hearing in just the
world around us
and some of those stories are really
serving us and some of the stories
aren't serving us and so we invite that
that introspection if you will in that
first step to just notice hey what are
we working with and then from there we
can define
based on what's going on with us in this
moment where we are right now what are
we willing to work on right we actually
talk about in life design how there's a
step before any of any of these others
can start called accept right because
sometimes we're ready to work on
something and sometimes we're really not
so are we ready to work on these things
that we're noticing and then if we are
how do we then start defining and
scoping things to take action around
and so so defining would be kind of you
you're you're distilling all that you've
learned from from
from the empathize step and you're
figuring out
what
you're defining is it defining it's
defining kind of next steps or defining
exactly
yeah exactly so you might not we we do a
thing called a balance assessment we
look at hey what's the role of work
what's the role of relationships in our
lives what's the role of play in our
lives how about our health and we take
stock of those things we often think
about work-life balance but that's not a
very helpful framing actually giving
ourselves more levers to pull more
aspects to work with and gives us a
chance to really focus in on areas where
we might want to want to define
something to change and so the
invitation is after you notice hey how's
it going and work how satisfied are you
how's it going in love how satisfied are
you how satisfied are you how's it going
with play how satisfied are you how's it
going with health how satisfied are you
you might notice oh well one of these
needs a little attention and so then the
invitation is okay well let's define
how might i improve my health in some
small way and then we talk about
incremental changes how can we make one
small change
after we've come up lots of ideas we
might pick one of them to try out
and that trying out in some tiny way
this is not talking about boiling the
ocean this is talking about trying
something maybe for a day or a week to
notice does it make a difference
and so that defining is that first
pointer hey what do i want to focus on
where do i want to generate some ideas
and where might i eventually take out
that's great and i you know i want to
walk through some more of these steps
because this is i think really helpful
we're getting a lot of audience
questions but i want to pause for a
second because we're getting
kind of two related questions that i
think are really valuable to talk about
so one is
hey i you know i'm mid-career is it too
late to start doing this or oh actually
i just graduated from high school is it
too late for me to start doing this and
so i could you could you talk a little
bit about
you know my understanding is this
applies any at any time and it's not a
thing that you stop doing yeah it's
something you just do once can you talk
a little bit about about that and and
maybe if you have some experience with
people at different stages whether it be
high school college students or or
professionals
talk a little bit about that and and how
how that's different for them or the
same
yeah i'm happy to so i teach students of
all ages
from uh late high school all the way
through uh well gosh almost to the end
of life really i've taught folks who are
17 i've taught folks who are 85. so
everybody is in the same process as i
mentioned of hey what matters to me and
how can i live a life where i will
thrive so that's a universal question i
think and as we go through different
phases of life different things or
different constraints might come up but
at the end of the day we're all asking
these same kinds of questions and this
process is age agnostic
at any given time we can stop take stock
decide where we want to and where we
want to put place our energy or place
our focus come up with lots of ideas
decide to try something and then test it
if you want to boil it all down it
really boils down to get curious talk to
people try things tell your story right
we're in this process of iteration and
building our way forward because life
keeps changing so if you're somebody
who's in high school you might not have
complete agencies to be perfectly frank
you might still live at home you might
have parents you might have teachers you
might have constraints around what you
can and cannot do because you are not
yet the captain of your own ship you
might not be providing all of the
resources towards what you're doing and
those people who are providing the
resources may have strong opinions about
what you can and cannot do and so the
the really the invitation is to to
consider where you do have agency so
when i work with young students i'm
talking a lot with them about hey what
are the constraints that you're working
under and how do we work inside those
constraints to generate ideas that work
given the things that you value the
relationships that you value and the
things that you're trying to work within
as we get older we might have a little
bit more agency but at the same time we
might have more responsibility now we've
got kids and mortgages and all these
other things and so the invitation here
is again to define what it is that
matters to you to consider hey what are
the constraints that i can throw off
because i've just decided uh those are
fears or those are other things that are
holding me back or i'm holding myself
back or where are these real systemic
constraints and then how do i ideate
within those constraints to create
prototypes that i can try to move the
ball forward
so it really is a universal process it
doesn't matter actually to me how old
you are what matters is are you willing
to get curious is this the right time
are you ready to try something and
trying something can be free right it
can be something as small as just
talking to someone about a future life
that you might want to live somebody out
there is probably doing the thing that
you want to do can you have a
conversation with them and learn more
about it that doesn't cost you anything
but it might be hard to do meaning
psychologically difficult to make that
first ask or to reach out and you may or
may not have the network so it may take
a few steps to get to that person and
sometimes that takes courage and it
takes time
so maybe time is the biggest resource
that i see
being a constraint for many of us but
yeah universally applicable i think pax
so so yeah so any time in your life and
as you're saying it's not just i mean
we're focused kind of on career today uh
because that's of particular interest to
lots of people it's a very important
part of all our lives
um and and but it can apply to lots of
things that you're thinking about how to
do better at school i mean you said you
offer a version of this course for for
stanford graduates is their undergrads
as they're planning their that's right
trajectory yeah that's right
um so we're i'm going to repeat the
steps again because people are there
they said i want to hear um uh i want to
hear those books again and then maybe
talk a little bit about
the kind of the next step prototyping so
the first step is again empathize right
so empathize with with yourself in this
case you know what is it you really want
so you're you're kind of figuring out
what your values are what you want out
of work what you want out of life and
then there's defining is taking that to
define what are going to be next steps
and then you generate some ideas for how
you might take those next steps and then
prototyping is that taking that next
step is it is right that's right so as
we define we're often asking ourselves a
question how might i
increase the balance and energy in my
life how might i
try out some aspect of let's say i want
to be a book author of being a book
author right and then we might generate
lots and lots of ideas and the idea of
ideation is about divergence so one of
the things i really like about this
process is it invites us to diverge
first often we're really we're really in
this space of trying to convert i'm
trying to get the right answer we're
trained by our education system to to
converge converge converge but in
reality before we converge it's nice to
really get all the ideas on the table
even the weird ideas and the wild ideas
and so i want to talk a little bit more
about ideation before we get to the
prototyping step because ideation is one
of those things that we often think
we're good at but it takes a lot of
practice to get good and it really is an
invitation to the wild and weird and
wacky that will often get us into a
space that we hadn't already
been in if we're if we're stuck and
we're in the same spaces over and over
we're having the same kinds of ideas
those ideas aren't helping us and so we
need wild and wacky ideas and so in our
classes we talk a lot about this process
of getting good at ideation how do we
break out of what we call schemas
particular trains of thought that are
very common and well trod in order to
get into new spaces that might help us
get unstuck and so we've got lots of
tools to do that people might have heard
of brainstorming we do some verbal
brainstorming in our classes but we also
do things like idea boarding or mind
mapping or using a technique called
forced morphology to really push our
brains into new spaces and to think
about other ways to attack the kinds of
problems that we're stuck on so that we
can potentially get unstuck so once
we've generated all of those ideas then
we pick some to take action on just like
you said pax the idea of prototyping is
what are we going to try and prototyping
is not making a huge leap prototyping is
at its very core about reducing risk
because it's scary to change and scary
to try new things so prototyping is
about reducing risk because we're going
to do something really really small
to see if hey if is there there there
and so we want to do something that is
cheap we want to do something that is
accessible to us it's easy we don't have
a lot of mental blocks against it i
wanted something that's fast because we
want to get this data quickly we don't
want to mess around so we want something
that we can do in a relatively short
order so cheap quick and easy that's
something to think about when you're
thinking about prototyping and what
we're really talking about is if we do
something we learn something
and if we do something we engage others
often in our process so all of a sudden
we've learned some things about the area
we're curious about we've potentially
met some people who are interested in
that stuff too so now we've got some
collaborators and folks on our team and
we've learned something about ourselves
hey how did that feel when i did that
thing and so prototyping is kind of
magic i think it's a bias to action
trying things and learning things on the
fly not by thinking about them but like
doing them and it and i think you learn
more that way for many of us than in any
other way
that's and that's great and i i wanted i
know something that comes up something
here and i think it's out of act it
might actually be out of stanford i
can't remember where the research is but
it was something like to create 10
products that succeed you need 600 ideas
or something right so we totally
underestimate the number of ideas you
need to generate to actually create
something that's successful so i just i
who knows if that that you know study is
replicated i don't know where it's from
but i know it gets thrown around a lot
here and it's a it's a interesting
meme or way of thinking about it that as
you said iteration is very important
it is and it's also very difficult for
people and prototyping is really scary
because we don't want to admit we don't
know the answer
we're afraid we're going to fail we're
afraid we're going to have to throw away
work
right all of those things for many of us
especially high achievers like many of
you on this call
are you kicking ass and taking names to
to put it just in kind of the vernacular
right it you are doing great work out
there and you are used to being a high
performer and if you are used to being
high performer the idea of trying
something new that might not work
can be terrifying
and so i really
i really just want to point out
we are going to fail sometimes
we don't know the answer the future is
unknown
and we are going to have to
um to recognize that all of our
successes are the summation of many many
small tribes of things where we have
learned that we're building on so it is
a little scary but if there was a better
way to do it i would tell you
it's pretty much necessary
and we're getting so i think let's if
it's okay let's stay on this kind of
that you're talking about change change
is scary right and i mean especially
right i want to try a new job but do i
quit my job can i afford to quit my job
um and and we're getting kind of
questions around that like what if i
want you know i want to explore a new
career but but you know i can't just
leave my current career or yeah we've
also gotten a couple questions of i've
invested really a lot of time into this
particular career and it's you know
important part of my conception of
myself but i'm not loving it anymore
and so maybe that actually comes back to
that empathize step but could you give
us some examples i mean you've given
some so it might be talking to someone
in that career but could you give some
other examples of what a a prototype
might be or some of the prototypes
you've seen that that are that aren't
that scary or that are
yeah absolutely the product conversation
is is easy and very accessible it's kind
of magical as i mentioned because you
learned something about the field that
you're curious about you also learned
something about yourself does that
person's story resonate with my story
and it doesn't involve you um selling
yourself for putting out a huge resume
or anything in fact if you're trying to
have one of these conversations i
recommend you don't send your resume
because it's not about you you aren't in
that moment job interviewing what you're
doing is really trying to get someone
else's story and trying to understand
how does that resonate and what are the
problems that they are working on in
this space are the problems i thought
they were working on are those the
problems that are interesting to me and
as you start having more and more of
these conversations inside of a given
domain what happens is you start
understanding the domain you start
having the language of the domain you
start sounding like a domain insider and
suddenly you are actually a much more
viable job candidate when and if you
decide to job interview so prototype
conversation is huge i want to just
hammer that home as being sometimes
people call them info interviews these
are a power tool and they work amazingly
well if you are thinking about perhaps
experiences though there are lots of
things you can do without quitting your
job let's say for example you're curious
about being a book author
well write a chapter write a paragraph
do some small piece of that
go sit in a coffee shop and write for a
while where do you like to write if you
were curious about writing try out a
bunch of different locations if you're
thinking about going to work at a new
company go sit in their lobby for half a
day just do your regular work from their
lobby on your laptop do you like the
vibe of the place are the people walking
in and out looking happy
do they talk to each other in the way
that you hope you will talk with your
colleagues do they seem like they're
hurried stressed does it seem like
they're relaxed what is the feeling of
being in that building you can learn a
lot from something like that again it
costs you nothing
you could try working or shadowing
someone for a day you could take on an
assignment while someone else is on
maternity or paternity leave you could
take on an assignment
that is small enough that you can get a
taste of some new aspect of a job
inside your current job maybe i'm
interested in moving from engineering to
marketing say
could i decide to write a marketing
blurb about the product that i'm
building and just bounce it off someone
in marketing in my company not because
my blurb necessarily would be used not
because i'm going to take over comms all
together but by just practicing that and
getting a little feedback from a
colleague i can learn do i like doing
that
am i any good at it to start what skills
might i need to build in order to move
into that space and so i think we often
think about huge moves i'm gonna go
intern for three months i'm gonna quit
my job and become a bartender in belize
well before i quit my job and become a
bartender in belize like why don't i
just make a few drinks for friends at a
party
right and and see do i like doing that
taking orders can i remember the all the
ingredients there's some little thing
that you can do to just taste
a tiny bit of the future that you want
to hold and so i think prototype
conversations and printed experiences
both are accessible to all of us
regardless of resources and regardless
of where we are in our careers
that and and just that that's fantastic
and it's interesting and i i want to
come back so again i'm going to say them
again right so
the empathize define id8 prototype test
and so
it just one one question so you say you
prototype something say you go i want to
be a bartender in belize right or
something and then you go and you do
some drinks you're like you know what i
make a terrible mojito this i can't
remember drink water
do you then i mean
can you go back to any stage so you go
back and go you know but but i also just
didn't like it as much as i thought i
would like it and so do you then go back
to the empathize stage or do you go
how how
i know it's not a linear process you
said that at the beginning can you just
talk about how you might okay i've
prototyped something what next and it's
it's not yeah what next yeah yeah
you can go anywhere so maybe you realize
that hey this project didn't represent
the aspect of the thing that i'm
actually curious about
i actually don't really care about the
bartending bar part it's really about
living in belize
right you know the the noticing of hey
why didn't i like that can give me some
more data i really like the interacting
with people and being able to serve them
drinks i didn't like the remembering of
the drinks is there some other way that
i could serve and interact with people
more maybe my job currently is very very
solo and so what i'm really realizing is
the thing i'm looking for is more human
interaction
or i'm looking for a different location
or i'm looking for so it starts giving
you more data and then then you have a
couple options maybe that means you're
going back to empathize with yourself i
don't maybe i need to learn some more
things about me right or maybe it's a
situation where i didn't define what i'm
looking for very accurately so maybe you
would drop back to there or maybe you
realize i just need some better ideas
about how to prototype this thing the
serving drinks at a party there wasn't
any money exchange like there wasn't
anything the idea of running a business
the bartending part it didn't get it
that bit and that bit is going to be
really important for me to understand
this more about this potential future
right so i want to come up with another
idea to prototype this further or maybe
it is just a recognition that hey i'm
not working on the thing that i thought
i wanted to work
on that's fanta yeah that's that's
really uh that's interesting just again
thinking it's not it's not a thing you
do once right it's not a thing you you
sit down you spend two weeks you're done
it's a constant process it's something
that you're essentially integrating into
your life that you're you're integrating
it's a process continually approaching
uh and and thinking about it
um i i think and i believe in the
class that you offer on the on campus um
that you do a thing called odyssey
planning is that right um
yeah could you talk a little bit could
you tell tell us a little bit about
odyssey planning and what that is and
how that relates to this whole process
yeah absolutely so after we've done a
bunch of small prototypes one of the
things we might invite people to do is
take a look at potential futures for
themselves for our students who are just
graduating they've never had jobs from
in some cases right so or if they have
had there typically have been part-time
jobs we do have some students who've
taken gap years and they've gone off and
had full-time jobs for some period of
time but many of our students haven't
even worked yet
when i think about folks who are out
there who are mid-career professionals
or folks in later parts of their career
they might also be asking the same
question what next what do i want to do
next and our temptation is to think i
got to figure out the best option
i've got to figure it out and then
execute
but the hard part about that is by
forcing ourselves into a singular plan
all of a sudden there's a lot of
pressure
so what odysseys are odysseys are three
very different visions of your next five
years we invite people to create a
timeline
for each of those versions of their
future self we invite them to look at
major personal and professional
milestones one in each year at least
if you've been thinking a lot about that
work love health play assessment we
might even invite think about what are
you going to be doing from work for work
in each of those years what are you
going to be doing to build relationships
in each of those years by relationships
by the way i don't mean romantic
relationships solely i mean
relationships of all kinds who are the
people that you care about and that care
about you maybe even pets or other other
other aspects of relationship in your
life what are you going to be doing for
play in each of those five years how are
you taking care of your health in each
of those five years and each of these
lives should be radically different from
the other
not because necessarily you already have
three random ideas for your future but
by forcing yourself to think about hey
what if the life i was leading right now
played out in the best possible way
what if i couldn't do what i'm doing
right now not because i'm not awesome
but because this industry goes away
right we've been seeing in a lot of um
places in the world shifts and what's
available in terms of work just because
things are changing computer science is
suddenly a thing that wasn't they've
been existent 30 years ago there are all
these different opportunities that are
changing and growing as the conditions
around us change so the idea that we
aren't doing what we're currently doing
and but we still have all of our
wonderful skills that we have picked up
over time that we could apply to a new
thing is an interesting one to ponder so
what would how would i apply my skills
to something else if i wasn't doing what
i'm doing currently and then we invite
people to think about the wild card life
this is the bartender and belize thing
for some of us right what would i do if
i had no constraints if i if i had all
the money i needed if no one would laugh
at me if societal constraints were
released if gender-based release
constraints were released if if if i
could throw off as many constraints as i
can and think super wildly what would i
do so those three framings are sometimes
helpful as we think about these five
these five year futures and then we play
them out so on paper and then we look at
them we notice how do i feel about them
because in some ways these are both
ideas and tiny prototypes right we get
the ideas out there we think of these
really divergent futures and then we
take a moment to take stock how does
that strike me
what would i call this life we have
people title the life
five words are less just a quick quick
title
you know
kathy bartens and belize
right and
and kathy takes over higher ed kathy um
runs back to you know heads back to
industry right those might be my three
titles and then i look at well
do i like it
do i have the resources to do it am i
confident i could pull it off and then
because we've done a bunch of empathy
work we notice is this coherent
with what i said i wanted to work what i
said my life view was
what i noticed in terms of my balance
assessment what i notice in terms of
flow all of the other tools and
activities that we've done in our class
so we get a sense of does this fit who i
am and who i want to become
and that invitation is doubled down upon
by sharing them verbally with our peers
so then we get into a group of three
people and each person shares out loud
those three visions of their future
and what's fascinating is you can see it
in people's body and in their voice
where they're excited
right you have the person who's like
well i guess what i would do
right as soon as you hear that in their
voice you know
this isn't maybe their story this is the
story that somebody else told them they
should do
or this is a story that they feel
trapped in or this is so they aren't
that excited about but on the other hand
if you hear somebody talking about okay
so then i'm gonna set up a hub of the
life design lab in australia and uh we
are gonna have an exchange program with
australian educators and art right all
of a sudden you can see in my voice and
in my body language i'm stoked about the
idea of setting up a hub in australia i
want to do that and so our peers can
reflect back to us
where we're energized where it sounds
like a story that our heart is in and
then that's new data
and once we've got these all laid out
right now it's like okay well if i
wanted one of these things
where would i start what little tiny
prototype could i run to test
because i'm super excited about starting
a hub in australia
how could i do that how could i start
testing that
could i make a connection with one
australian educator and build one piece
of curriculum together
would that be
fun as fun as i think it's gonna be
as as meaningful as i think it would be
and if it is then i can keep going in
that direction and if it's not i can go
back to those odysseys i can make a
fourth a fifth
i can combine them together
but i can start noticing hey where are
their themes where are their threads
that i want to take action around not
huge action not quit my job and move to
belize action just trying it out with
action because i'm going to sneak up on
it and learn as i go
that's fantastic and i i love i love the
officer that you're sitting there
reading these like you clearly spent a
long time reading these live
paths that you've planned and then
you're just not excited about something
and so i was just thinking i mean that
for some people that might lead you back
to the empathizes you're like i thought
this was consistent with my values and
what i wanted out of work but clearly
it's not and and so now i need to do
some more uh reflecting
uh yeah yeah but
this is some plans but they're not plans
like you know it's a funny thing the in
the in the in the book designing your
life bill and dave titled these odyssey
plans and i actually more and more just
call them odysseys um or even just ideas
because
at the end of the day you probably
aren't going to write down a five-year
plan and then execute it to the letter
over five years
in fact i asked my students at one point
if you could if you could write this all
down and then you'd be locked in you're
forced to execute it over the next five
years exactly as you've written it today
how many of you would want that and you
know there were a handful people who put
up their hand and then a bunch of other
people said no and i asked one of the
one of the women who had said no she
didn't want that why not
and she said this brilliant thing she
said because i sure hope the me of
tomorrow is smarter than me of today
and i loved that because what that
really is is acknowledging that we are
always getting smarter we're always
growing and changing and in fact it
would be foolish to lock ourselves in
based on what we know today because
we're going to get more data we are
going to gain new skills we're going to
realize new strengths and so to give
ourselves the flexibility to constantly
be prototyping and growing and changing
in many ways is much more powerful
position to be in than somehow locked up
with a plan that i developed maybe when
i didn't have all the data that i
currently have
this is
that is fantastic yes and that that's
that in itself is a really important
lesson to learn i know sometimes when
you especially i'm sure this is true for
undergraduates they're like i'm going to
graduate and then i'm going to be in my
career and that's it for the rest of my
life right it's like no no no no no
that's the only career i'm going to have
which is ridiculous in fact the data
that most of our most of our graduates
right now are changing jobs every two to
three years
they are slated to have 15 to 20 jobs
over the course of their lifetime and
two to three fully separate careers
fully separate think about that that
means they're going to do things that
are completely different
and maybe there are going to be careers
that they will have
that currently do not exist
that they will build and create as the
world changes so this idea that the
decision you make today is forever that
you're locked into it is just not true
it's just not true
maybe that was the case in you know my
parents and grandparents lives that
people tended to be in one job and stay
in one town and and you know retire
there but that's not the reality that
our students are living in and for many
of us that's not the rally we are living
in regardless of age because things are
shifting around us with or without our
consent
this is fantastic and we're reaching the
end of the of time and we are getting a
lot of questions about resources so i
want to repeat that there are some links
uh there are some links in your console
that can take you to the live design uh
the life design lab and i believe kathy
you've got more resources that are
linked out there if people are
interested there is a book about about
this as well um yeah and
and then maybe can you say so there is
this course that's happening
there is a a course that is happening uh
on campus
in what's remote it's it's it's online
this next spring quarter um it's called
uh designing the professional can you
tell us a little bit more about that
course and what's involved in it
yeah absolutely so we're offering the
class designing the professional in the
spring virtually it's a 10-week course
we'll be meeting online for two hours a
week plus some bonus sessions
extra hour
probably five or six over the course of
the quarter so about
30 hours of of material in person or in
conversation with others and then we've
got uh a bunch of assignments of course
in between all of that that will support
people in going through this process
so it starts with empathy really it's
really this this process of noticing hey
what is my lived experience who am i
what are my views on work what are my
views on life really digging into things
like balance and energy digging into
what helps people thrive thinking about
how can we leverage some key tools in
exploring potential careers how might we
in fact look at our existent career
experience and notice things like how
much change do i like in my environment
where do i like to have impact how can i
learn from my past experiences to guide
me and potentially having some perfect
conversations and experiences around my
next step in my career we spend a bunch
of time thinking about decision making
how do i make choices how do i weigh
options what are the what are the tools
i could use if i've got some
opportunities what are the tools i can
use to develop opportunities how can i
come up with ideas for opportunities for
myself how can i create connections with
others how can i ask for what i want at
work i mean for those of you who are
having
jobs out there one of the things you
might be thinking about is ah my boss
would never let me and in fact
sometimes the boss would if you can
really frame things appropriately how
your professional growth and the goals
of your group or of your company could
overlap in a really powerful way that
would then allow them to retain you
frankly right now we've got the great
recession going on many a company is
interested in keeping their wonderful
people and so how could you make that
ask so we're going to be talking about
that in the course we're going to be
talking about creating these odysseys
for yourself how can you start
prototyping into those odysseys so it's
a whole journey really of figuring out
how could we start becoming the person
that we want to become we're not just
going to talk about career we're going
to also talk about how does career fit
in with the rest of your life because
let's be honest we've got careers they
take up a lot of our time and energy but
there's also all those other things that
make life worth living what about family
what about the things we do for fun what
about our own spiritual beliefs what
about our own
views of why we're here on this planet
how does that all fit together in a way
that creates a life of meaning and
purpose so that's the overview of the
course
20 to 30 hours of
time spent together doing this work and
then a bunch of work on your own doing
some reflection i want to say one thing
about the community part because it's
really important and and pax mentioned
the book
you can absolutely just go and buy the
designing your life book and work
through all the exercises by yourself
there's a workbook online too i think
amazon sells it for 15 bucks
and i recommend doing that because it's
really it's really good stuff
but even more i recommend finding some
other people to have these conversations
because like we were discussing before
when you speak things into the world and
in our classes we ask people to do this
a lot there's a ton of work in small
groups and pairs and groups of three
where we're practicing these things
we're practicing the ask we're reading
our work work view aloud we're reading
our world view aloud we're sharing our
odyssey plans aloud and we're hearing
one another's and so then you get ideas
from folks who have different
perspectives and ideas than you
then you can steal those ideas designers
are all about radical collaboration and
sharing ideas so you get more ideas you
get potentially ideas to get unstuck and
then you also get this feeling of not
being alone because we're all in this
process together it is not that oh my
gosh i haven't figured it out yet
there's some something wrong with me
none of us haven't figured out we're all
working on this as an iterative process
and so being in community around these
questions is magical
and people can reflect back things to
you that you can't see yourself either
because you're too close to it
or because as you say it out loud your
body and your voice tells you new data
so there's something about the community
bit that for me is critical to life
design this idea of having a life design
team and working with others is
perhaps more powerful than anything else
when it comes right down to it
that's fantastic yeah always having
having you had also mentioned just
reading it a lot creates a level of
commitment it creates a level of uh you
know accountability for a lot of this
ownership yeah absolutely and
so we're at time and we actually you
went over so thank you so much for
subscribing sorry
no that's perfect i i don't have any
objection i don't think the audience has
any objection um we are getting lots of
questions about future offerings so
there's this one course that we
mentioned being offered this spring is a
is a graduate level course it is
it is a stanford for credit course so if
you were to take it
through uh stanford online you would be
taking it as a non-degree student you
would get a stanford transcript but i
know that you have a lot of other
resources that are out there and we're
getting questions i think even from
people at stanford about you know what
are the future offerings is the life
design uh lab is that the best place for
them to go to see where what offerings
are out there and what might be
happening in the future um it's a great
place to go it's a great place to go the
uh the book website is also available so
that's designing your dot life um so
bill and dave have a website about the
books themselves and and so you could
check for resources there but really the
life design lab at stanford is the place
to go as you're thinking about offerings
at stanford and there you'll see some
other recorded talks
you'll also see some links to the
classes on campus
there are potentially events that we do
on campus so workshops that we that we
do for particular groups on campus so
check them out i i absolutely welcome
any of you in the course that we're
going to be doing the course will be
graduate students and you if you decide
to join it and what i love about that is
that graduate students are in a very
particular part of their career path
they potentially specialized to an
incredible degree and they're thinking
about how can i use that specialization
out there in the world in some way and
you might be someone out there in the
world who's curious about next steps and
talking to these specialists about their
experience might give you new ideas and
so there's this beautiful radical
collaboration that i think will happen
in this spring class very excited about
it
perfect well thank you so much kathy i
think uh that's it and we appreciate
your time we appreciate all of you
joining us today
thanks everybody
you